I know what Lauren berbert loves she
likes Vapes she likes Democratic men and
she likes to spend a little bit of her
campaign funds at her boyfriend's bar
she maybe grabbed the wrong credit card
after she was hammered you know she was
hammered you ask all these people what
their secret fantasy is you go to the
Middle East and you're like what's your
secret fantasy and they'll go someone
from the other side I love the fact that
she's trying to portray that she was
naive to the fact that he was a Democrat
I would think that would be one of their
first conversations considering her job
is being a congresswoman right that
might come up he might have probably
made a joke about it she you know she
was drunk she probably I don't [__]
like you and she mushed his face she
went like that so tell me how come
you're not wearing a dress what are your
kids transition Fu out face I don't
[__] like yeah but you can't but she
did say they're no longer dating once
she found out he was a dirty Dem I don't
buy it for one second we all know she
thought it was hot